[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel Ramsey
personality is my co-host today he is a
big star on YouTube you on the George
camel show and also of course co-host of
the smart money happy Al and author of
the brand new book that comes out next
week called Breaking Free from broke the
Ultimate Guide to more money and less
stress there it is right there all right
Courtney's with us Courtney is in
Colorado Springs hi Courtney welcome to
the ramsy
show hi thank you so much for having me
sure what's
up my question is how do I protect or
how does my husband and I protect
protects our finances against his money
hungry
ex-wife money hungry ex-wife why would
she have any access to your finances
she's called the ex-wife for a
reason um basically our main concern is
could she pull more child support when
she finds out that he's been
married I'm I'm I'm sorry would she get
child support increased because got a
rais is that what you
said um because we got married could she
take she doesn't get more child support
because you got married child support is
based on his income not
yours
gotcha okay so how else would the crazy
ex have access to your husband's
money that was the only way I was
thinking I've heard that they do yearly
it they do some they do because your
husband your husband has children and he
should support those children and the
law agrees with that
idea correct and if he gets more money
as his income he's supposed to give more
to his children that's that's not a
money hungry X that's just dad taking
care of his
kids right has she contacted him is she
making threats or is this just all kind
of in your head right now what could
happen um havn't contacted him I guess
this is just me trying to make sure we
protect
ourselves okay well you're in good shape
as long as your husband is willing to
give the legal percentage of his income
to his children under the law for child
support which he legally and morally
should do um if if you if you want
protection from that I can't help you
but as long as he's willing to do that
you don't need protection from anything
else she can't get anything else she has
no access and or if your husband is
spineless and just gives her money
because she yells at him or
something I mean has he got that
problem um no she's not okay so he's not
he doesn't just hand her money just
because she puffs up or something right
correct okay that's just a behavior
issue that's not a legal or a financial
issue but yeah I mean sometimes people
are intimidated by their exes or
whatever and um we have to just kind of
correct that by saying you know X in
front is a reason yes X means no mo no
mo that's what that means we're making
sure the courts decide how this goes
down not his emotions or her and so that
that's the important part it sounds like
this is largely right now just a fear
versus a reality yeah like you have
discovered that no one likes your
husband's ex oh well that's really you
know you know makes because she's a
greedy jerk okay whatever that's fine no
trouble uh but she's still over there
and she's the ex and the only
involvement you have is just around the
children and so we'll try to be nice and
pleasant and give the appropriate amount
of Child Support as long as you're
trying to do that then uh I don't think
you're going to have any issues there's
nothing nothing she can just you know or
unless she shows up at the doorstep and
your husband just caves and starts
handing their money but that's a husband
issue that's not a protection issue then
yeah this was simpler than I thought it
would be I thought there was some crazy
stuff going on but it's just child
support as far as we can tell yeah so
yeah very reasonable well there's a real
Dynamic when you're the new wife and the
ex is over there and the distance is
crazy that's a still connection that's a
dynamic yeah those kids are still going
to be in his life so you're going have
to learn to manage it yeah it's a it's a
thing Christians in Missouri hi
Christian how are you hello I'm good
good how can we
help um I joined the Navy and I'm
leaving for boot camp in June um they
cover most of your expenses and so I
have most of my five foundations covered
after I get my $500 emergency fund set
up am I ready to start going to step
five because I paid cash for my car they
pay for college and I don't have any
daily expenses that most civilians have
to pay for what should I do with the
$2,000 paycheck I get yeah so you're
18 yes sir thank you for serving your
country sir and thanks for going through
the personal finance curriculum I can
tell by the way you're talking it stuck
with you you went to that in high school
didn't you I'm actually still in it I'm
I'm graduating in May and I'm taking it
this year oh wow fantastic so boot
campus immediately after graduation huh
yes sir wow look at you okay well we
will graduate you from the high school
curriculum to the adult curriculum which
will mean you start with a fully funded
emergency fund which is 3 to 6 months of
expenses uh you're making $2,000 a month
most things are furnished so we might
call that emergency fund
$5,000 not 500 500 is for high school
students yes sir okay but now you're
you're you're going to leave high school
and enter the land of grown-ups so we're
going to put you on a grownup plan and
that's going to be an e so your first
goal is going to be a $5,000 emergency F
you have no debt right correct okay you
paid cash for the car and so beyond the
e Mercy fund you can begin investing
with earned income and maybe fully fund
a Roth IRA and there's probably some
retirement options through the Navy I
imagine okay maybe a TS next
question is um in this curriculum we
learn everything interest rates based on
a 12% interest rate for compound
interest how do I actually get that good
of an interest rate look at your tsp in
the Navy it's the thrift savings plan
they have a Roth version you'll do that
if you look at the C plan in that uh
it's north of 11% it's not quite 12
right now average at the C plan the C
plan it's the common stock plan I
wouldn't put it all in there I would put
some in the S and in the I the I is
international s is small cap C is common
stock those three I'd probably put 80%
in the C and 10 in the S and 10 in the I
and that's your retirement plan Roth
Thrift Savings Plan the tsp with the
military okay okay and when you leave
the military you can roll that out to an
IRA if you want to okay how much uh
would you recommend me putting in that
retirement fund 15% of your income after
you have your $55,000 set
aside okay okay you're very wise to get
ahead of this Christian I want you to
continue all the way through boot camp
to give to make sure you are writing
down each month before the month begins
where every dollar goes because there's
a lot of really stupid stuff 18year olds
in the military do with money and I
don't want you doing any of that a lot
of crazy crap out there son so just be
careful continue to be calm and wise
like you are right now and you're going
to do really well you'll be so wealthy
my friend thank you again for your
[Music]
service
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
well George it's this
week 300,000 people already know it's
this week and some of you apparently
didn't know but we're going to let you
in on the secret to 300,000 you're
invited easiest sales pitch ever because
it's free what percent of Americans say
they live paycheck to payche check the
answer is generally for 30 years since
I've been doing this around 70% so if
you drive down your street somewhere
around 7 out of 10 houses have too much
month left at the end of the money and
too much car in the driveway and too
many boats and seos and sew all need a
sister so you got two of them yeah crazy
just
breeds and there you go this says
Americans say frequently live a paycheck
to paycheck according to recent survey
Harris poll that
65% do live paycheck to paycheck but you
know either way you know what you can be
looking good and
broke that's most of America I mean it's
land of the free home of the broke and
we all look good and we're comfortable
with our payments until we're not and
that's why we're doing this thing and
George did you know you do know but I'm
going to pose this as a hypo I don't
know yes you do know I promise you that
the stupid has a gravitational pull oh
that's a new science uh lesson yeah once
you get in Orbit to stupid it holds you
in the orbit it has a gravitational pull
to is that one of like Einstein La you
just keep going around it's a Ramsey law
but we we we we adjust other laws of
physics here to meet our it has a
gravitational pull so if you want to
break free of the orbit of stupid oh I
like that it require how do you break an
orbit it requires extra energy you can't
just uh keep doing the same thing you
got to do something different take some
real inertia you got to you got to blow
it up right and so that's what we're
going to do if you're stuck in the
cycle of being
scared of worrying about
inflation worried about interest rates
worried about the
president uh we can help you because
we've been helping people for 30 years
break the cycle your family curse is not
a permanent thing the neighborhood you
grew up in is not a permanent thing none
of this is a permanent thing cuz you can
decide so to kick off the Year we're
hosting a free live stream this Thursday
January the 11th at 700 p.m. central
Time this is the biggest live stream
we've ever done it's over 300,000 folks
already registered it's me Dr John
deloney Rachel Cruz George camel to my
right Jade warshaw all going to be
talking about navigating money anxiety
breaking the cycle breaking the orbital
pull of stupid bad money habits that
keep you stuck practical money tips that
actually work and for the first time
ever we're going to give away $10,000 10
people are going to win $1,000 each as
you are a viewer not signed up you are
actually viewing because we will put it
up there and you will have to be
watching at that moment to qualify so
you need to be watching and signing up
to do this go to ramsy solutions.com
breakthe cycle and register and that
then when you're watching we'll know
you're registered see you can't just pop
in there so you get registered break the
cycle ramsy solutions.com breakthe cycle
and it's going to be huge it it's
already huge yeah the numbers are
boggling my mind I think people are
ready in 2024 just to break free from
broke and they're not where they want to
be financially but they know there's
hope out there and hopefully we can step
in and help them how it works it's going
to be fun looking forward to it it's
really really cool that's happening this
week next week is the launch on
Georgia's new book so we're going to
have a lot of fun things in the next
couple of weeks here for you guys and uh
we'll be telling you more about the book
a little bit later Rita and Charlie are
with us they are in San Jose California
hey guys how are
you great how are you better than I
deserve what's
up so I I'm 50 I just married my husband
Charley for a year and a half I bought a
home 20 years ago in Santa Clara which
is nearby santose and the home is
completely paid off I just paid it in
December and it's probably worth 1.4
million he has a house in the mountains
that has about 200,000
dollars less to pay off in
mortgage my dream has always been to get
a another home in the by the ocean in
mesino and so we recently just looked at
a home there that was three
$300,000 needs a lot of repair so
probably around
$500,000 so my husband's idea was to
take out
a a loan on my house that was paid off
where do you live I don't really want to
do that you live in any of these
properties currently we do so we we live
in the mountains parttime at his home
and then we live in the Bay Area in in
my home when I work I'm a nurse oh I see
okay so you live in the paid for home
you've got a mountain home that's not
paid for and you're talking about going
further in debt to buy a third home a
second toy
yes
okay uh well you guys are fairly new to
Ramsay um we teach folks to get out of
debt and stay out of debt as the best
best path to build
wealth okay not go into debt
particularly for
toys I've I've got you know vacation
homes and and uh pay cash for them those
are
toys yes if you have a third house now
you're splitting time between three
houses you're consuming all all three of
these houses partially when you add up
what you are paying to stay there per
night it will make you throw
up yeah that's a toy you need to be able
to pay cash for that toy so you're going
to move backwards and go another half
million dollars into debt instead of
moving forwards financially I would I
would decide what I'm going to where I
want to live and um what's your
household income
now uh he's retired so
so it's about one well mine is like 180
between the two of us okay I I would
have a game plan to get the mountain
paid off and once it's paid off I would
start investing in Saving and when I had
some extra cash I would buy the house on
the beach that's what I thought yeah
that's that's kind of Grandma's
oldfashioned way save up and pay for it
yes but it
works okay yeah you're you're you don't
want to go backwards because here's the
thing he's retired so how how RI how old
is
Charlie he is here with me he's 55 oh he
quit early okay he did he good for him
just heating and air conditioning okay
cool well I got a feeling he could go
make a ton of money by the way doing
something if he wanted to just for the
fun of it don't have to for sure but he
could if you wanted to advance some of
these
um some of these goals um yes you know
uh so earning some income I'm 63 I I
mean I still work 40 hours a week so not
because I have to just because I love
what I do and um so that that's kind of
he does a lot of he does a lot of work
on the side so there's a lot of people
who need his help yeah that's good okay
so I mean that the I you do not want to
Ender your golden years with home
debt that's what I figured I said I
don't want to have another 20 30y year
mortgage when I just paid it off it
destabilizes your golden
years okay and as we've studied
Millionaires and we studied 10,000 of
them the vast majority of them have all
of their home and everything paid for is
one of the big elements of their million
dollar net worth the other one is of
course their
Investments okay and so I want you to
you're millionaires already based on
what you've told me because of just the
equity in these two properties I don't
even know what your nest egg is so
you're you're you're a millionaire but
you don't want to go backwards and
destabilize this debt adds risk more
debt adds more risk and that's what was
when y'all started talking about this
Rita and your stomach tightened up
that's what you were doing you were
measuring risk your stomach said
no yeah and helocs are going to put your
home at risk and so the bank could take
your home if you default you misstep in
any way and that's not the kind of
retirement I want no you just everything
paid for big old pile of money this is
retirement uh this is the Golden Years
baby and and you're on your way
congratulations on the new marriage uh
so let's just take our time unfold this
the right way go with u Rita's plan not
Charlie's Sorry Charlie s literally
finally we've been waiting for that one
ready to say that but you know there you
go this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit visit blinds.com
to get up to 45% off that's blinds.com
rules and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America the phone number here is
88255 225 the Ramsey Show question of
the day is brought to you by neighborly
your hub for Home Services neighborly
offers a helpful winter maintenance
checklist that you can download for free
at neighborly tocom and for the more
challenging stuff in and around your
home neighborly has local Pros to help
find out more at neighbor.com
Ramsey today's question comes from Sam
in Michigan Uncle Dave I'm 37 married
with no kids yet my net worth is $1.1
million 600 in portfolio 500 in equity
in my home which is worth $ 900 I make
about $200,000 a year have no Consumer
Debt and have our three-month emergency
fund I just got into hunting and there's
several shotguns and rifles I want but
the MS doesn't see why I need so many
guns Uncle dayve being a man of great
means with many guns what is a fair
ratio he said I'm also about to pull the
trigger on a new lond Rebel XL as my
first fishing and hunting boat it's
39,000 out the door I'm paying cash for
it but would be pulling the money from
my portfolio to do so I feel it passes
the burn it on the floor test what is
your take thanks so much for your time
this is a fun question live like no one
else so later you get to live and give
like no one else well done Sam in
Michigan yeah that's fun that's fun Sam
the only only thing I'll tell you is is
that there seems to be a a ratio that
every time I get a gun she gets a new
expensive
purse TI for T there seems to be a
tradeoff there so um that's the only
thing I'll tell you all I heard here was
about you buying stuff I didn't hear
anything about her getting stuff so I
think there's some uh some enjoyment
with money that you're learning to do
that is within reason and um it's it's
not a certain number but uh I'll all
getting aside it actually does generally
cost me a purse depending on the gun so
uh or something else but yeah um I'm
going to get one of it's like Revenge
spending right yeah none of this has to
do with money this is just her feelings
about him owning all of this all these
toys I can tell you Sharon has exactly
the same opinion she has absolutely has
no need to understand why I need all
these Firearms but she doesn't know
about zombies that's right the zombie
apocalypse I mean you have to be ready
so um no seriously dude it's just a toy
it's just a thing uh I mean
uh whether it's whether you're
collecting guns whether you're
collecting uh whatever the hobby is
whatever your hobby is whatever the
thing is you collect whatever the thing
you enjoy doing hunting uh you know
boats skiing fishing whatever the trick
is just to keep it in balance and that
both of you have a say so
so I and all all joking aside I still do
talk to Sharon we don't do any purchases
around our place without both of us
being in on it I don't walk in and go I
just spend $88,000 I don't do that um I
could but it just doesn't it's not how
we got here the way we got here is
working together and both of us
communicating and talking about it and
she doesn't go spend $88,000 on a
whatever without talking to me and you
know we and but 99% of the time it's
like yeah sure because it's it's it fits
the burn test I can burn that much money
in the middle of the floor that means we
can enjoy the item it's not going to
cause us financial trouble we're not
buying it for someone else we don't we
quit doing that a long the right motive
yeah so and he's not he's not buying
these guns for someone else he's buying
them for him so uh so is the key here
you know Dave doesn't have to Value all
the things Sharon values and Sharon
doesn't have to Value all the things
Dave values but there's communication
involved and she goes okay it's in the
budget Cas you're probably experiencing
this around purchasing things for the
new baby oh yes there are things that
you don't understand I don't you know
most men don't understand China cabinets
I still don't we don't understand China
that we don't use and we don't
understand a expensive cabinet to put it
in none of this makes to us it was up to
me we just use paper plates just throw
them see there you go and if it was up
to her he'd have a BB gun that's right
so there you go so I mean it's just
there there's some things like you don't
have to understand everything to see
that your spouse gets Joy from it and
that it is a reasonable purchase within
the thing now where we do run into
trouble is when someone buys a boat puts
it on payments m
that you know they got $660,000 in
credit card debt and they want to buy an
$8,000 shotgun now that's just that's
childish that adds Financial stress to
the family yeah that's that's not that's
the opposite of what we're talking about
he's got a million dollar net worth he's
37 years old so he can afford a shotgun
or she can afford a nice purse or
whatever the thing is that you're
worried about there uh the trick is when
you get out of control with this so
you're just trying to do that
and uh I mean TR I'm kidding around I'm
being snarky about it but it's really no
joke there are things that I buy that
Sharon agrees to but has
no understanding why I want them at all
and the same with her I'm like you want
to do you know what I mean she took a
trip with a bunch of girls this summer
and I'm like really there you want to go
there but it I'm not going so what do I
care she wanted to go it's her
experience you let her have it so that
that's the thing so just just hold
things with an open hand but I I I the
the the biggest glaring thing I see in
this Sam is not whether you can afford
to do it uh is that you didn't mention a
single thing that she gets to do while
you're doing all these things and you
really do have to have some whatat of a
balance it's not Tit for Tat exactly you
know like $
4,622 I get she get to spend on a
$39,000 purse that's
that's it could happen but um yeah so
there you go I mean that that you just
you don't have to understand everything
she didn't have to understand everything
can we do it and it doesn't affect our
family
negatively and do we still have bro in
the budget to invest do we still have
room in the budget to
give if this goes
sideways um has have I caused myself a
problem and I none of that none of
that's here no do you see it no I mean
it looks good on paper it's more their
relational issue now you just left out
that I get called Uncle Dave twice in
the email I like that that's pretty cool
it's better than Grandpa Dave right Papa
Dave that's nice that's that's what the
grandkids caller the grand kid that's
not insulting Not For 37y Old Men well
there you go did Uncle for that there
you go I'll go with that all right
Melody is with us in Denver hi Melody
welcome to the ramsy
show happy Monday gentlemen hey how are
you hey I'm doing good how are you to
doing better than we deserve what's
up okay uh let me present my question
and then I can talk a little bit about
myself uh question my husband and
I uh and I do not have any debt good um
The Only Exception is our
mortgage and um while we are saving for
our three to six months emergency sound
do you think that's a good idea we also
do some investment in the me time if yes
what kind of investment tool would you
recommend
well thanks for the question Melody I
love that you guys are on that stage
it's a fun place to be when you're
building for the future instead of
paying for the past and if you're
following through with the ramsy baby
steps you guys are in baby step three
and those are done one at a time one
through three and so baby step three 3
to six months of expenses and a fully
funded emergency fund once you have that
and only when you have that should you
begin investing 15% and the reason is
because you need financial Foundation
under you cuz if you're investing and
you don't have the emergency fund in
place you're still at risk here and so
the goal is to kind of eat the
vegetables first get out of debt get the
emergency fund now we can invest 15%
with no problem versus people investing
3% while trying to save while trying to
pay off debt we found that if you do too
many things at once you won't make any
progress yeah you know for years George
we had folks that well they get a match
at work and they're just really geared
up about the power of compound interest
they really want to start investing and
so they go stinking load up their 401k
and have no money at all m in an
emergency fund well guess what they go
back into debt no well they'll go back
in debt or they use their 401K oh for
their emergency fund you know that you
know the car transmission goes out I got
no money you
know dies I got to get two airline
tickets to get over across the other
side of the United States somewhere and
you know that four grand ends up as a
401k loan a credit card debt or worse
than that they cash it out because you
did things in the wrong order you get
penalized not technically penalized by
the government but penalized just called
stupid tax yeah well baby step three
it's a hard one you don't have the
excitement of paying off debt you don't
have the excitement of investing but you
got to make this a priority to get that
emergency fund in place yeah you need a
rainy day fund takes the drama out of
life yeah Dave you ought to be positive
I'm positive it's going to rain you need
a rainy day fund this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Church Hill gives
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
more
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Lamar is in St Louis hey
Lamar welcome to the Ramsey Show hey
thanks Dave good talking to you you too
man what's up um I guess around 2010 or
so um maybe a little bit before that I
started listening to some of your um um
I don't know whether it was a podcast or
I think it was even tapes or something
that you put
out and since then you know I've used
all your information to u to make myself
uh do the things that you were doing I
don't know whether you called it baby
steps back then or not but uh I started
doing it and um I'm 63 now uhhuh and
I've been doing it for all this time it
work and I found excuse me did it
work well it worked a little too well I
think at a point now in my life I'm 63 I
I was raised on a farm so I've been
working since I was six
yeah and I sit and watch some people
retire and they'll go sit on the couch
and they expire you know the next year
yeah absolutely and right now I could do
that if I wanted to what's your not
worth
but uh uh I'd say four to five million
or something like that yeah way to go
I'm proud of you but you know I've
got uh probably five years of um of cash
for emergencies and then I've
got uh land I got
um I don't owe anybody any money I got a
nice home I've got I got investment real
estate that it's paid for it needs to be
uh developed but I'm not going to attack
that so my question to you is you know
I'm kind of post Ramsey now what kind of
what kind of um no you are poster Ramsey
you're the poster child for Ramsey
you're you did it man you live like no
one else now you're in a position so
your questions what is what to do now
yeah what's next well you enjoy what you
do for work still and you're able to do
it well you know I'm getting to a point
where you look at Brown I work for a
corporation
and um you know he sitting there
thinking okay you could go out you'd be
fine I'm getting be somewhat of a
dinosaur I guess even though I'm a
chemical engineer but thing is is um you
know I should have move on I mean
there's no pressure from the company to
get rid of me it's just one of those
things you know it's just a question of
if you if you hate going if you hate
going to work every day you've earned
the right to quit and do something else
and you could go start a little business
or you could develop that land I mean
you can find something to do yeah I
already own a business on the side too
so okay I mean but if you don't if you
like going to work and you like the
people and you know there's nobody says
you have to
quit well people people think that but
you know Dave's still here yeah and I'll
be here a while longer Lord willing the
creek doesn't rise right yeah you know
and the other thing I do is see I own a
training facility for diamond sport for
pitching and hitting and everything else
it's associated with baseball and fast
food softball
wow is that kind of a passion project on
the side things like that is that a
passion project or something you doing
for money Lamar are you doing that
baseball thing as a passion project or
something you're just doing for money
passion pure passion if you worked over
there every day would that make you
happy well you know and I'm thinking I'm
hoping that may take up some of my time
I don't know where they take it all we
put that in in 20
8 and it was put in specifically for
fast pitch softball and it's it's
baseball now too but but it within uh by
2021 we started winning state
championships in our little area here in
in fast pitch softball so it was very
effective and this is not a promo just
I'm just trying to tell you what yeah
but but it's almost a bucket list thing
and I've almost marked it off well you
could expand it take it to another
community you could have five of them in
5 years instead of just one of them or
you can just keep running that go you
said something about developing that
land you might do that um you know I
I've cut back to four days a week I
don't work Fridays most of the time if
we're doing something around here I come
in but um most of the time I'm off and
so and that gives Sharon and I time to
do stuff and uh I can work I can p
around with other stuff here and there
but uh you know it's up to you I enjoy
what I do and so I will my plan plan is
to do it as be on this microphone as
long as I make sense when I quit making
sense James is going to take me off and
we're going to blame George that's right
we'll probably meet both of us at that
point we'll probably just run
reruns why you think you think you you
won't make S you you you're planning on
going early yeah I'll go with you da
you're going to get like early whenever
you go I'll go early retirement I'm
kidding I don't think so we'll have ai
Dave by then so I'm not worried about
that but I do like the idea of Lamar
dreaming a little bit that's where
you're trying to get to do is just write
some of these things down things that
you've been itching to do for a long
time and never got around to it and if
you enjoy your work as a chemical
engineer and the people are reasonable
and the company's reasonable and you
want to keep doing it there's nothing
says you got to quit just because you
got $5 million and he's right the people
that check out and just sit on the couch
they they expire I like way he put that
like bad cereal it expired this mustard
expired don't leave the milk on the
counter it expires yeah that's right
he's right that's what happens because
you know man was made to do stuff woman
was made to do stuff he's not scared of
work and he doesn't hate it it's a
beautiful thing yeah that's fun don't
you don't have to follow what everybody
else says to do it didn't you didn't you
didn't get $5 million doing that Kelly
and Milwaukee how are
you hi I'm good thanks for taking my
call sure what's
up um so my question today is about
whole life
insurance um so my husband has a um
whole life insurance
that was started for him by his
grandparents when he was a baby I'm
sorry yo Gerber
plan and luckily we are not um paying
the premiums on it yeah his parents are
paying the premiums
y um and it currently has a $70,000 cash
value um and so I want to know if it
would be a good idea to cash that out at
this
point and use it for a larger down
payment on a house
yes okay then do you have
children we do yes do you have do you
have life
insurance we do enough to take care of
you if he your husband dies or vice
versa without this whole life
policy yes good cash it in and use that
money for something good sitting in a
whole life policy it's making 1% and
when he dies they're going to keep
$70,000 and pay only the face value of
that
policy whole life life insurance is the
payday lender of the middle
class they've been screwing and
tattooing the public for decades since
they were babies getting away with it
since they were
babies yeah they put they have put so
much money into this policy that it
makes me want to barf for there to be
$70,000 in there m yeah I me and my
husband know that like we're not going
to be are you in control of this policy
can you all cash it out or you got to
talk the parents into
it um we would have to talk to his
parents but they are very open to us
doing what we want with it good cash it
out use it for a down payment on the
house good question and you already knew
that we were going to say that I'm sure
easy and that's a good caveat Day when
people go hey I'm going to cancel this
whole life policy make sure that you
have term life in place 10 to 12 times
your income first yes before you cancel
it you don't want any Gap in coverage
there right that's when the Devil comes
for you so you know you you want to make
sure that you're protected and you don't
have any gaps and then cancel the whole
life policy yeah but man it hurts that
sunk cost fallacy of we've been paying
these premiums for decades since Jimmy
was in diapers it's somehow sentimental
at that point it's so special to us yeah
gosh I don't know how they Market these
Whole Life policies so well that Gerber
got involved and went we can make some
money off of these Gerber's been doing
it long as I've been on the air yeah but
I mean buying buying investment products
from a baby food
company that just smells like a dirty
diaper kind of sounds stupid to start
with doesn't it when you just say it
that way I mean it's just like you know
I'm going to I'm going to buy my clothes
at the transmission store yeah buying
any insurance as an investment product
stinks but buying it from a baby food
company Next Level it's just something
there something very interesting
hopefully we can reverse the trend Dave
put a cute little kid on the outside of
a ripoff policy a little baby I think
that's what does it a little cherub a
little cherub on that cherub on the
outside that jar of sweet potato oh my
goodness both make me want a
barf this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
w
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George Campbell Ramsey
personality host of The George camell
show on YouTube and co-host of the smart
money happy hour with the one and only
Rachel Cruz he's my co-host today open
phones atle 88
25225 Austin starts this hour off in
Raleigh North Carolina hey Austin how
are
you hey thanks for taking my call sure
man what's up hey so I have a couple
questions um I feel like I'm in a little
bit of a pickle um so just long story
short I'm a registered nurse um
traveling right now my wife is a
stay-at-home mom we just had a baby this
year umat got into oh thank you I
appreciate it I got into a nurse Senor
school this year and I start in may wow
um uh thank you yeah we're very excited
um it brings on a lot of new challenges
since we can't work for three years it's
um a little bit stressful but we have
about combined about 40 Grand in debt
right now I'm wondering a lot of that
doesn't have any interest I'm wondering
if I should go ahead and wipe that all
out right now because I'm able to with
my fund or should I save that pay the
minimum monthly payments with no
interest and save more for school since
my wife will still be staying at home
and um I won't have an income for three
years um I can maximize my Federal loans
when we get to that but um obviously not
having an income makes me very
nervous so you're planning on borrowing
all the way through
this yeah I think so since I feel like
my salary afterwards I'll take care of
that in one or two years
yeah you're making the Assumption
everything goes
okay yeah exactly um with emergency
funds and everything but you never know
what life could throw you to at the same
time so yeah so I'm a little bit nervous
right now yeah yeah I mean going 300K in
debt I'd be really nervous um I I got to
tell you I think your career path is
phenomenal it's excellent I think your I
think your method of getting there
really sucks
really yeah scares me to
death um I mean I can't I I if you know
if I was going to as much coaching as
we've done in the last 30 years about
money stuff I if I was going to dial in
what some someone could do to make a
pile of money it would be exactly what
you're doing it's a great income stream
you're going to you're going to make a
lot of money if everything goes okay if
it doesn't go okay you're going to have
a huge Mount Everest to
miss yeah exactly you don't pass the
boards something happens to your health
something happens to your wife's Health
in the middle of this you have to stop
and take care of her I mean you you can
have a car thing I mean anything can
come along here this scares me to death
so the company that you work for you're
doing travel
nursing yes
sir where are you going to practice when
you graduate do you have any
idea um so right now my dad's also a
nursing athetist um at his work they
offer a stien program so I plan on um
whenever his boss gets back to him I may
be eligible to do a stip in program
which gives me anywhere from probably 10
10 to maybe 30 grand a year to get
through to work with them for um we
still have to negotiate the the amount
of time that I'll have to do there but
I'm it'll be for a set few years um so I
have that I also have are they going to
pay for the are they going to pay the
tuition and a
stien they're just going to pay the
stien so so my anesthesia program I went
to one of the cheapest I picked one of
the cheapest in the nation thank God
since I'm in the state that's good much
45 Grand for 45 or um 45,000 for three
years oh excellent okay man I can cash
this wow so why don't you work your butt
off between now and then and pile up
that much yeah that's exactly what I'm
uh planning on doing W you just pay cash
for
it yeah um it's either I want to pay
cash for that but should I take care of
the debt right now so you have any money
right
now yeah you need
$85,000 between now and
may pretty much and your wife is going
to be working while you're in anesthesia
school to pay the bills if you don't get
the
stien yeah she's she's also a registered
nurse and she can pick up whenever she
wants essentially she's GNA be doing
that that's called the price of what it
takes to get your butt through
school exactly can you make 85k in the
next 6 months you can make 85 okay
between now and
may yeah it well the contract rates are
really down right now especially for
Pediatrics so I'm struggling to find a
contract to where I don't have to leave
my family for so long I think are you
limited to
Pediatric yeah I just do Pediatric
Intensive Care right now I know are you
limited to that with your
licensing yes yeah with my experience no
not your not your licensing just your
experience yeah just my experience and
and your mindset listen you need to go
change the oil in cars or whatever it
takes to find 85k I don't give a crap
about your experience I want you to go
make a big pile of money between now and
May and have no debt and $45,000 in your
pocket and a game plan for your wife to
work enough for y'all to eat while you
finish this degree if you don't get the
stien and then you do this debt free you
do it debt free because you're going to
come out making 200 to 300 if you'll do
this
right okay aren't
you yeah yeah I should come making at
least minimum probably 180 200,000 200
coming out and you'll be three before in
an ey blink it's a great career field
but all you're going to have to do
listen here's the thing this is this is
a time that you and your wife do
inconvenient things that are harsh so
that you don't have to do inconvenient
harsh things
later yeah absolutely you pay a price
you pay a price to get this done and
it's going to be a it's going to be
inconvenient it's going to be no fun
people are going to roll their eyes and
say why didn't you just take out a
student loan because you're an idiot
people that tell people that tell you
that that you just look at them and say
because you're an idiot I'm not taking
out a student loan I'm going to do this
I'm going to work my way through this my
wife's going to work you both have
nursing degrees go make a big old pile
of money man right now real quick crazy
go crazy act like your life depends on
this cuz here's the other path you
lazily stumble in to taking on $150,000
in debt and then you graduate and people
say well you're nurse anesthetist you
got to have a good lifestyle upgrade the
car man get the car payment and it never
ends yeah and so I want you to graduate
no debt making 200,000 with that baby
and going we can do whatever we want you
can stay home forever honey if you want
I got this 200 coming out of the gate
300 in an eye blink yeah that's amazing
very cool and it's not that hard I mean
80 making 45 to cover the programs no
biggie paying off 40 you can do that
that's 85 and and the two of you roll up
your sleeves you've got great
Great Hearts great brains great degrees
a great Direction lean into all of that
and make this work and if the stien
tradeoff is reasonable I'll take that
stien deal but if it's not reasonable if
if they want 10 years for 30 grand well
screw that no thank you those handcuffs
ain't worth it not doing that juice
ain't worth the squeeze as they say yeah
there you go so just got to you got to
measure that out see if that's worth it
but it might be easier for your wife
just to work a few cuz she can work 12
some mean work 3 12s while you're in
school real easy man it's everywhere
there's a shortage of nurses as you know
everywhere this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves with chm
she can help other families who need it
and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host
today he has a little thing happening
next week little thing we have a book
launch here it's a major major thing
book launch next week for George
Breaking Free from broke comes out next
Tuesday on the 16th and if you pre-order
it you are going to get all kinds of
goodies like a $100 worth of stuff
instant access to Georgia's newest talk
show me the money you'll get exclusive
access to an online private event which
is a Q&A with George uh you're also
going to get an audio book and an ebook
of this book and this book is so fun
Breaking Free from broke the Ultimate
Guide to more money and less stress we
uh the only downside of the book was we
had to uh invent a new font to cover the
snark it's the snark font because George
is the king of snark I had a lot of fun
writing it and uh you know the research
and the humor coming together is a
beautiful thing and we got one of our
first reviews on the website Dave
because people got the ebook early if
they pre-ordered before the new year oh
so you can get it can you get it now if
you get the I think if you order past
New Year you have to wait until launch
day now but who knows okay don't ask me
I don't you know I don't make the I
don't call the shots but this review is
hilarious from Michael K he said came
for the snarks stayed for the smarts
quite possibly the funniest and easiest
Financial book to read once you start
you won't be able to put it down I
wasn't able to You'll laugh out loud the
whole time while learning this book is a
mustre for everyone especially young
adults the amount of data back knowledge
this book provides while being such a
joy to read is staggering Michael what a
kind review Michael the checks in the
mail that's an ad that's beautiful I
know a great ad very kind of I couldn't
have said it as well myself I'm glad he
said it and you know when you're writing
a book you hope all of these things are
said about that's exactly what you set
out to do that's what I set out to do
can I make a really e easy to read fun
Financial book that's the financial
literacy you never have it's so research
backed cuz there is there's a ton of
research in it I could have jokes all
day but I wanted to make sure it was
Ironclad with data so it's not just my
opinion and uh it's in there 130 sources
so pre-order before the 15th and you get
$100 worth of stuff when you buy a $20
book not a bad deal at all Breaking Free
from broke by George camel at ramsy
solutions.com hit the store and you're
going to get the free bonus items go
ahead and get the book now um
George I have
bought Sharon was making fun of me
because I ordered a new book last night
you love books big reader I have bought
so many book I have read some wacky
books in the
past uh three weeks I've read in the
past four weeks I've read three full
siiz hardbacks and um I mean just
strange stuff and I and then I what ends
up happening with me is and there were
all three good books actually all three
of them one of them was um uh Michael
eser Easter who did the uh Comfort
crisis he's got a new one called uh
scarcity bring and he was on on the show
to promote it and gave me the book and I
just just now read it he was on he
become a friend of ours now yeah and
he's uh the book's really good it's it's
talk about research based but yeah and
then I read a couple others that are
just odd books but uh I knew odd people
that needed to read them that were
friends of mine and so I'm buying all of
these books and sending them to people
now yes and Sharon's like would you quit
buying books you're in the book business
and I'm like no I'm in the book business
that's why I love books you have a whole
Publishing House you love books so much
I own a publishing company so shut up
yes I'm not gonna of course I'm going to
buy books George's book only 20 bucks
it's a great deal hey it helps us if you
pre-order it it helps George hit the
bestseller list which is a marketing
touch we would appreciate you
pre-ordering it if you're going to get
it plus we and that's why we bribe you
and give you a $100 worth of stuff extra
to pre-order it between now and next
Monday the goal is to reach new people
so they see this on the list and they go
must be a good book all these people
bought it and I believe it is so I love
that you know a guy holding up on an
orange cover holding up words that's
George that's all it takes I'm pushing
back against the toxic money culture
Dave that's that was the idea I saw I
saw the flex yeah we hid my muscles you
can see the you can see the muscles
they're covered in denim I don't want to
scare anyone off don't don't want
anybody to be freaked out by the
physique here all right Alexis is in
columia South Carolina Hi Alexis how are
you hi Dave hi George how are you all
doing better than we deserve what's up
in your
world uh nothing much I am trying to
decide I have an H track that I need to
replace I just went into this house last
year and it's like 40 years old so it
needs to be replaced um and so my
question is do I I want to max out my
Roth area this year um but I also know
that the a track is going to be around
12 to 15,000 to rep place and so my
question is do I stop a hold on maxing
out the rth array and build savings or
continue to do both how much debt do you
have uh I don't have any debt besides my
mortgage good how much money do you have
saved $99,000 that's your emergency
fund yes okay what's your household
income um per month or annual
either um so 5,300 a month take home
um take home that is take home how long
you been doing
that um just for the past year okay so
that's where you got 9,000 and got rid
of the debt and got a
house right but the the furnace is
running it's just
old right it works I'm just so if you
save $2,000 a month for three months
you'd have enough for the
furnace okay did I do that is that right
why was that wrong that's right 2,000 a
month yeah you're right for three months
what is that wrong or can you do
that um so with the
5,300 3700 goes towards my mortgage and
bills and then I put a th in Savings
mortgage and bills oh okay how much is
your mortgage huh my mortgage is
$1,400 okay all right that's better I
feel better where's the other I mean you
got a whole 20 300 worth of
bills um well the way that I budget my
finances you have okay I'd take a good
look at that budget and see what can we
cut right now and if there's anything
you know that feels frivolous that we
can cut temporarily I would do that to
create the margin to save up for this
HVAC yeah and then just be
systematically putting 15% of your
household income into retirement but um
if you've got an emergency fund you to
be able to save up some money while you
have an emergency fund it might take you
four months I don't know but um does the
HVAC have four months left in it
sure I think so yeah it's just making
noises like it's on Christmas story or
something right yeah and I would also
get some bids cuz $115,000 feels like a
lot Dave you've replaced some hvacs in
your day I don't know what the what they
cost now depends on what it is yeah but
yeah you always get two or three bids
and learn something when you're buying
something that expensive and you know
try to find a friend that knows people
in the business and you can teach that
can teach you about this whole process
and you know all that kind of stuff so
that you can keep from you know maybe
it's 12,000 instead of 15 that would be
a cool thing that's a big difference
yeah and maybe you don't need the
Bentley of furnaces maybe you just need
the Chevrolet of furnaces I didn't know
they made those Chevys in the furnace
business I'm just um making this up
right here I do that pretty regularly
open phones at
5225 so George one of the things that
she can do with the every dollar budget
is to sit down with the app
and usually when someone has broken
things out the way she is she's got only
two buckets 3700 is my expenses
including her $1,400 payment right and
and and then then I'm free after that
and and that might be true it might be
true but I would rather you just say all
right I'm going to make sure I take care
of the necessities life food shelter
clothing Transportation utilities right
there on the budgeting app and then go
okay uh I got to take care of my
insurance over here too all right what
else have I got and you just keep
looking at it and go all right now where
is the rest of this going because every
time someone sits down and does a budget
particularly in every dollar budget you
always have this sense of where's the
rest of it going it's a little mystery I
make that much where did it disappear to
I don't have that many bills it's um and
John Maxwell our friend says that a
budget is people telling their money
what to do instead of wondering where it
went and so when you start doing a
budget you will feel you will have the
sensation as if you got a race every
time every time and um and I can tell
you're not doing a detail budget because
you've got it broken down into just two
buckets huge buckets and I love every
dollar because you can create syncing
funds so I can start saving up $1,000 a
month for that repair and it will
automatically set it aside for me which
is great
absolutely this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
w
hey guys Ramsey solution started small
and grew fast because of that rapid
growth there were times when our systems
slowed us down that's why we switched to
netw Suite it works for us and it'll
help your business too whether you're
starting on a card table like I did or
you're well on your way to becoming a
multi-million doll Company netw Suite
can scale with you and help you
communicate and plan better because you
know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting Analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net site will help at your speed
and whatever your situation more than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netw Suite today and find
out how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
netsuite's free kpi checklist designed
to give you consistently excellent
performance at nets.com Ramsey that's
netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsy
Solutions on the Dead free stage Raymond
and Lana are with us hey guys how are
you better than we deserve I hear you
welcome welcome to Nashville and uh
where do you guys live South Haven
Michigan which is near cazo in Southwest
Michigan uh and I I think there's like a
football game tonight there might be and
you're here instead we're here instead
wow wow here to do a debt free scream
how much debt have you paid off
128,000 in 2 years good for you and your
range of income during that two years 90
to 120,000 or so cool what do youall do
for a living special ed teacher MH and
I'm a behavioral specialist in the same
school system awesome very cool what
kind of debt was the 12 28 mostly
mortgages and how or car payments and a
little credit card M paid off your house
two houses two of them yep wow I'm
looking at weird people look at you no
debt in the world anywhere of any kind
exactly how does that feel wonderful y
baby step seven wow look at you way to
go way to go so what happened two years
ago that put you on this ramsy journey
well Co kind of hit us and then we kind
of started selling things in the house
house we sold the whole basement we just
put that on eBay Marketplace and
everything and we just sold sold sold
people were coming up and down our
driveway every night our next door
neighbor thought we were selling drugs
that but it was my brother so he knew we
weren't selling
drugs and and we live in Michigan so
there was just a corn field between me
and my brother so out in the middle of
nowhere so you you sold stuff like crazy
but what what what caused the switch to
flip to cause you to do all this well we
were looking at finances and we figured
we could
retire by we couldn't retire until we're
67 MH and that didn't appeal to us at
all so actually we just retired we both
just retired from the school wow she
paid off everything in how old
are you I'm 61 59 all right wow well you
beat that 67 over the head way to go
yeah way to go so how'd you get
connected up with us podcasts and and I
prayed we were praying about it and
every time we prayed the name Dave
Ramsey just kept coming up we couldn't
go anywhere without someone mentioning
Dave Ramsey so wow so um that's a little
scary that's a haunting prayer right
there yeah so I yeah we really felt like
we need to open the book okay you know
there we go and game on anyway this
makes sense let's try this wow what are
the properties worth about each property
is about
250,000 way to go and how much in your
nest
um so we have about 500,000 in
retirement all right so you're
millionaires yeah look at you baby steps
millionaires just like that who would
have thought it yep yep people were
making fun of us because we're driving
old cars and the hub caps fell off a
raised car he was driving to 2009 Malibu
and he wasn't going to replace them so
people were laughing and he wore his
shoes till they had holes in them I
wasn't quite that good but right you're
just cheap it was cheap yeah I was cheap
look like you upgraded the shoes I don't
see any holes hes but yeah we had um
eight different jobs in addition to our
teaching jobs wow so so we just went out
and really worked hard and you know if
somebody needed help in a restaurant I
would you know wait tables if somebody
needed help bartending Lana would
bartend and we just rolled with that and
and uh then we started doing side
businesses we both have a boat well we
have a boat and we've had it for a
number of years and I would wax the boat
and paint the bottom of our own boat and
during Co you know other people needed
that Services done so we started doing
that we started a nice little business
now and we're going to use that like you
say to help Finance our retirement get
Social Security we're going to be
washing and waxing boats so well why not
we got a side business so we're semi
retired really it's not glamorous but
it's yeah it's a lot of fun good money
it's good money yeah and steady work and
steady work yeah and it's funny we'll be
washing a boat in a slip and then two
other people will come over and say can
you come wash ours and then we pick up
new clients that way free marketing
right there it is yep way to go you guys
way to go so what's the first big thing
you're going to do now that you're 100%
debt free to celebrate um we're going to
come to Nashville and do the debt free
scream oh wait who knew yeah we listen
to those podcast sometimes 8 hours we're
in the barns alone while we were
watching Ing and waxing bolts it would
be a beautiful day our friends are out
on Lake Michigan sending us pictures of
their toes in the sand and drinking
margaritas and saying where are you guys
so we would listen to the podcast the
podcast was our Lifeline wow and we
really uh said we're you know we we just
hoped we could be here one day and now
you get to have your toes in the sand
living like no one else that's right and
be generous and we started with baby
step one and we paid off that smallest
debt and then that debt rolled into
other debts and and and as we paid them
off we had more money to pay the bigger
debts and then pretty soon we were
living on only 25% income and everything
was going to debts and then even after
we paid off our last mortgage we
continue living on 25% wow you put all
that into retirement 401ks and 403bs
loaded up yeah loaded it up at the end
way to go thank you way to go ex if you
had one piece of advice to somebody
listening they're under the boat waxing
out there trying to get through it
what's the one thing you tell about this
whole process that you learned you can
do it you can do it don't give up stay
dedicated we started late you know we
were 55 when we started and we we
thought we were doing okay and uh we
were Dave Ramsey is and we we uh sat
down and did a budget and thought whoa
we are not where we should be so you can
do it you can do it it you get things
paid off a lot quicker than you think
yeah two years went by fast it went by
fast and now you're free yeah now we're
free yeah I love it I'm proud of y'all
congratulations thank very very well
done what a great story I love that I
want everyone out there who's in their
50s to go when can we actually retire
and if it's not when you want to it's
time to make some changes and you guys
are living proof it took two years and
you turn this whole thing around Gaz
turn the boat around two years there
that was for you Dave that's good I like
that very well done all right Raymond
and Lana hey we've got uh The Total
Money makeover for you the baby steps
Millionaire's book for you you're you're
probably in there somewhere and uh
Financial Peace membership you can give
those away or use them or however you
want to do it those our gift to you to
say thanks for coming all the way from
cazo to do your debt-free scream
128,000 paid off in 2 years making 90 to
120 count it down let's hear a debt-free
Scream 3 2 1 we're dead free
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah something happens George when you
identify a goal that is bigger than
people's opinions ooh when you identify
a goal I want to retire by 5960 not 67
and I don't really care what you think
I'm going to go wax boats I'm going to
wait tables 10 bar I I'm going to sell
stuff some stuff out of the side door
that my brother thinks we're doing drugs
over here I mean you see you just don't
care what people think all of a sudden
you can do all kinds of crap it is a
freaking superpower I mean it's amazing
what can happen when you're willing to
do anything to get something you never
had and Raymond and Lana just living
proof they just busted their butts and
this wasn't a 10year journey it's two
years twoe journey I could do anything
for two years and I have at times the
price I mean the price you got to pay a
price to win nobody AC accidentally
wins you know and they didn't
accidentally win they leaned in hard
they went hard man you know what they're
completely done what happens is you
accidentally paid for $250,000 housing
live this mediocre life for 20 years
where you're broke and all it takes is
two years of intentionality to clean up
the mess yeah and man they're Heroes
absolute Heroes fabulous couple but
that's that's what happens all of a
sudden you know you get dialed in you go
hubcaps I don't need hubcaps hubc caps
are for you they're not from me I mean
I'm good I'll get me some hub caps later
and I'll get a different car too so
there hello this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
Dave Ramsey here George camel is my
co-host Ramsey personality open phones
at
225 we're glad you're with us thanks for
hanging out zenya is next she's in Los
Angeles hi zenya welcome to the show how
can we help uh yes thank you guys for
having me on sure um my question is me
and my husband just got out of debt
we'll be completely de free by December
of this year
congratulations thank you wa minute
you'll be you will be you got out of
debt or you will be out of debt we will
be out of debt by December of this year
12 more months yes
okay so my question is we want to open a
media company because we want to start
working for ourselves but we're not sure
which route to take because everybody's
been telling us either to take a
business own and I don't want to do that
because we're just getting out of debt
and I don't want to go back into it
everybody's stupid don't do what
everybody says on
anything okay yeah so what what kind of
a media company are you
starting well we want to be able to make
our own movies because I write a lot of
stories cuz I'm disabled and I so I just
am not a great arthor so we figured
making it into a film will be better but
everybody's enjoyed it but I'm not a
great writer why do you need a media
company in order to write a film script
could you not sell the
script um pop people have told me I
could but we want to just make make it
into an actual
film okay I'm telling you there's
companies that will buy the script if
it's good and they'll make it into a
movie and they'll cover the production
cost versus you you know going 100 of
thousands of dollars into debt to do
this is a bad
plan I had no idea about that yeah I
would start there and just start doing
your research on this industry and get I
mean you're in La get connected with
people who are in this industry and
that's going to be your best bet to take
the next step but I I don't think you
need to start a media company today and
you definitely should not do it with any
debt okay what do you what do you do for
living now hun um I'm disabled so my
husband's the bread winner I do try to
do some side gigs on the side like on
online like side hustles but um we it's
been a struggle because we got hit
really hard at the pandemic and that's
how we got into
that yeah what what does your husband
make uh right now he's um making about
16,000 a year 16
16,000 how are you guys
surviving well we got lucky getting this
rent this rental unit which we're only
paying 450 a month
for what is he doing for
work he's essentially taking care of me
because I my health is not the greatest
so I always need somebody
247 so who who is paying
him um we I am in this program called
inh home support services and they're
paying him to be around me
247 but they're paying him minimum wage
to do this yes yeah this this is a
problem it's not
sustainable it's not
but if you if you have to have care
247 how are you able to make a
film hello yes I'm here sorry that's
okay if you have to have care 247 how
are you able to make a
film that's true I I try to do what I
can at home though cuz I I have moments
where I can do stuff sitting down yeah I
mean I'm not I'm not questioning you
being lazy that's not what I'm saying
but I'm saying if you're so limited you
have to have 24 care 24hour 247 care um
I don't think you're going to be making
a film unless I'm missing
something no you're not you're right
okay so I think George is probably on to
something let's start writing and see if
we can write a script that we can get
someone to buy the script
and I think that'll be helpful and long
term we've got to think about your
husband's career and your care and how
we can accentuate those and create more
income for the household and it's not a
media company is certainly not borrowing
money to go into debt to to start a
media company we definitely don't want
to do that Kyle is with us in
Gainesville Florida hi Kyle welcome to
the Ramsey
Show hello hey what's
up I'm looking for some expert opinion I
guess well we'll call one no I'm kidding
how can we
help uh so my wife she's been staying
home for the past three years with the
kids and she's got some retirement
accounts from when she was working uh
with local government uh and she's been
saying that we should cash them out to
pay off some stuff and I'm a CPA so I'm
always thinking about the tax
implications of that and early penalty
distrib early distribution penalties and
things like
exactly just just trying to get an
outside perspective yeah what's your
household
income uh 95 okay so cashing this out is
going to cost you 30% plus a 10% penalty
right right yeah so that's a 40 I'm
going to borrow money at 40% interest
honey to pay off my
debts right I don't think so how much
debt do you
have uh we've got about 38,000 not
including the mortgage okay and you make
95 I think you I think you just get on a
tight budget and let's roll up our
sleeves and get this paid for as quick
as you can because you don't want to
borrow money at 40% interest you you
knew that before you called
right oh I I did like I said this is an
outside
perspective he's just trying to win the
argument and you
did way to go Kyle I think you need to
show her a plan as how we're going to
pay this debt off with future income and
current savings let's let's get on let's
get on a budget get on the every dollar
budget get the app up tonight yall get
it out and look at it lay it out there
on your website I mean on on your
desktop show her this is what we're
going to do but borrowing money at 40%
interest is never a good plan and that's
the equivalent of doing that when you
take that much in penalties you give
almost half your money to the government
to cash us out early no let's roll that
old retirement plan into a good IRA and
some good mutual funds and try to make a
little money with our money
money say honey I love the spirit of you
wanting to become debt free so quickly
but here's a better way to do it Beverly
s's famous quote there's no shortcut to
any place is worth going there's a price
to be paid to win and you don't want
have to make things hard on purpose but
we don't want to cash out retirement the
only time we cash out retirement is to
avoid foreclosure or bankruptcy or you
know something extreme like that but
it's not to pay off debt and it's
certainly not to buy crap that kind of
stuff because you're going to get
hammered you you get hit with your tax
rate plus a 10% penalty it's ridiculous
it's horrible and using any kind of debt
on top of that to you know people taking
out hel loocks or the 401K loan to pay
off debt using one kind of debt to pay
off other debt it doesn't make sense and
so our plan always points back to using
current savings stuff you can sell
future income that's the best path to do
it yeah and just crank down your
stinking lifestyle and get in attack
mode that's the hard part I think people
truly don't want to sacrifice yet
they're willing to pay 40% interest by
we're looking for a shortcut yeah
looking for a shortcut so I don't have
to tell myself no do it the hard way the
first time otherwise it's called a
stupid tax and you call us after you
make the mistake well I mean learning we
all part of part of growing up and part
of being an adult is just learning to
say no to yourself and to others I mean
and by the way no is a complete sentence
you know it's the ancient word no one
says it anymore if you say no to people
now they just freak out hurts their
feelings oh well they're they're they're
mad at you I mean you're you're some
kind of evil monster you know you you
suggested that I be denied I'm just
trying to live my truth Dave yeah you
suggested that I don't how dare you
suggest a no in my life I I'll help you
with a big old no it begins with an N
ends with an o o just like that a big
old no you just put your tongue towards
the roof of your mouth release Air give
your lips a little kissing motion it
sounds just like this no I think that's
Universal every culture understands that
one no my dog understands that shake
your head uh-uh
no no it's a good word but can't say no
to your dog Dave I say no to a lot of
things I say no to Dave even Dave gets a
no so I mean come on hey that's called
controlling yourself you know and not
picking on Kyle by any stretch but just
everybody out there I mean if you don't
get the concept of no you're going to
struggle the rest of your dadgum life
with part of your life no I can't eat
that dadgum chocolate you brought in
here a while ago that's right I actually
tried to offer Dave some chocolate
during the break you did this guy
practic what he preil child no it's how
I keep my physique I offer Dave
chocolates and I don't take them no get
away from me George no it's how you do
it right there this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
n
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel Ramsey
personality is my co-host today the
phone number is8 825
5225 Melanie is with us in Philadelphia
hi Melanie welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi so excited to be here thank you
for taking my call we're honored how can
we help um first of all let me just say
George I'm reading your book is super
awesome oh thank you so much appreciate
that yeah no problem so my my question
is so my husband and I are in baby step
two um I'm working two full-time jobs
he's a school teacher and also has a
training like a personal training um gig
on the side that he does he rents his
own facility um but he's had it for four
years and my concern is that he really
hasn't made any profit off of the
business he makes just enough to just
pay the bills at in the business um at
what point do I have that conversation
that it may not be worth his
time um in the business just because
it's just not bringing
in anything that doesn't make money is
called a
hobby right it's not a side hustle it's
a hobby
he likes work he likes personal training
so much he's willing to do it for
free almost I mean he makes some money
but not as much as I think he should
because he's been doing it for you're
changing your tune in the middle of the
call which is
it how much does he really make net
profit on the
thing probably it varies every month so
we can run range anywhere from 1,500 to
like 2500 a month profit
oh well you said after he pays his bills
he's not making much if anything he's
not what bills has he got the rental on
this
place yeah just the rental on the place
and then he know he has like um that his
utilities are included with the rent in
the facility and then he has like I know
his internet or something that he pays
okay so he's getting 1,500 to 2500 in
what's the
rent uh
1,600 so it's almost everything so if he
doesn't make 1,600 in a month he loses
money right
okay well I I I don't think it's
unreasonable to sit down tonight and say
honey I I we've got to look at this as a
business and and we need to look and see
what we've got to do with your pricing
and the number of clients that you have
to make what you're doing over there
profitable mhm because it's not okay
that you're spending all this time over
there and potentially even losing
money right so let's get let's get out
the numbers let's get out the numbers
and run a p&l on this thing and just
just sit there tonight and run a
spreadsheet on it how long's he been
doing it um he's had this place now for
four years okay well let's go back La
you know for the last 12 months pull
pull the revenue and then put in 1,600 a
month then put in the internet fee a
month and and let's see if we've really
got a profit or not figure out what his
hourly wages on this my guess is you
know you made 500 bucks and you spent
600 hours over there right you're making
a dollar an hour come on man you know as
a business owner how do you like at what
point do you say like it's is not viable
anymore how much time he's supposed to
be like an adult and stuff he teaches
children yeah yeah he does what does he
teach uh health and fette okay and how
how what what age
children uh anywhere from kindergarten
to high school okay and so we would
assume that they know how to do basic
addition of
subtraction yes and he
should if he's teaching them I mean
really
I he needs you know you need to sit down
with him and say I I need you to look at
this Through The Eyes of a business and
let's look at it for a few minutes and
let's see if you think this is
worthwhile
but I don't you don't need to tell him
he needs to he ought to be able to a
logical adult male female should be able
to come to a conclusion on this without
his wife or husband telling them I mean
you ought to be able look at it and go
I'm making a dollar hour no that doesn't
cut it you
know I'm supposed to be providing for my
family during this time no no and you
guys are in debt and so I think that's a
part of this equation is we need to
actually make money right now so here's
the thing anytime we're in a business
situation with our Entre leader
leadership clients on a side hustle or a
small business idea we do one of a
couple of things one is we have to ask
ourselves what can we change to make
this
viable and if the answer is there's not
a change that'll make it viable then
it's time to shut it
down okay I mean I think you guys are
going to look at this and figure out I
think you're going to look at this and
figure out you put $18,000 or what is
$119,000 in rent into it last year mhm
you know and he brought in ,500 bucks I
think that's what you're going to find
yeah I think so too and and you know so
and then how many hours you spend over
there divide that into 500 and you look
at him go honey what part of this is
smart none right right so you know
you so we something has to
change this is not okay we have to raise
our prices increase the number of
clients both or we got to say we're not
doing this anymore okay yep GNA have
that conversation I appreciate your your
opinion on that I guess the other thing
is you know do you have a
basement we do why don't you do it down
there yeah 1,600 bucks ahead per month
instantly another thing people do now is
they'll go to your house and do the work
out there oh yeah yeah and the other
thing they can he can do is just go work
at a gym that already has personal
training and they hire him and pay him
money so he doesn't have any of the
overhead yeah so there's a lot of
options part of the equation on the
business model may be getting rid of
this rent and suddenly yeah you're
you're doing inhome work and in your H
work in in other people's homes for them
you know personal training you go visit
Jim then you go visit George and then
you do whatever I mean that's the dream
and they pay you money you know and um I
have a gym in my house we did that for a
long time and so um my wife made fun of
me she said you know the guy's counting
for you you
can't count to 10 needed in that moment
paying that guy a big money for counting
no I'm paying him for
accountability there's that but I I I
can count to 10 I already can do one two
I can I can count you need a guy yelling
at you other than the guy in your head
we don't need anybody yelling at me but
um but we need someone just I know if
he's going to come over there then I'm
going to do the workout right otherwise
I might find my little butt on the sofa
you know that could happen and so that's
that's what you know that's what a
personal trainer does sometimes we know
what we can Google the workout we hire
the personal trainer because we need
that level of handholding right now yeah
I mean that's okay yeah so I mean do he
could he could provide the service like
George is saying charge even more to
come to people's homes in person um and
or in your basement and or if you're
going to keep the location you got to
make the
location having the location needs to
cause you to make more money than not
having the location would have cause you
to make I think you're going to get rid
of this location at a
minimum this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Stephanie is in
Indianapolis hi Stephanie welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi thanks so much for taking the
call sure um my hus husband and I have a
question we bought our first home three
and a half years ago got a really great
interest rate at the time the house was
appraised at 250 before we put on a new
roof and we're having to replace a
furnace and that's part of our
frustration it's an older home almost
100 years and at one point there's I
suppose there's a Tipping Point
somewhere where uh you keep putting
money in the old house and keep the good
interest rate and just get a little more
Equity out of it or a broader picture we
don't want to maybe be here forever a
little more land a little newer house
maybe at a 100 years old and and we're
just wondering how much longer should we
stay um we can't get to the Aesthetics
part of of renovating so it's just
maintaining the house which we can do
but it's just frustrating and it's like
okay what point is it maybe they cute
those historics are cute but they're a
pain in the butt they don't build them
like they used to thank God yeah oh gosh
uh so yeah I've done a bunch of those
they're very interesting um yeah I I
think you're
done I well I I feel done now because I
got willed out um the furnace that we're
replacing at some point hopefully this
week yeah um I think you're done doing
carbon it was giving out carbon monoxide
I'm like oh my word I'm could to die so
what's wrong with SH on
it um I'm just I I don't want to
necessarily move and then move again in
three years so it'd be nice to where you
going to move where you going to move
that you got to move in three years who
said you had to just move just don't
want to move up in house and then feel
like I have to move up again you know
I'd like to move into a house that's the
idea more the ideal um not that there's
a perfect house but let me help you with
this you thought that was ideal when you
moved into
it no this one wasn't but it was a
blessing for where we were at for a
firsttime homeowner the house has been a
blessing okay um how long have you owned
it I guess it's a money it's a reach
like to get the house we want it's a
little bit of a reach so don't reach
just buy a house that's not 100 years
old and not having a screw with it all
the
time okay that'll feel like a dream home
compared to this the my this idea that
you're going to buy something that
automat automatically is going to be
what you want for 10 years it's not
there's no automatic cuz life changes
things shift your needs your dreams
everything changes and you're going to
move again you don't have to move every
three years but um but you also don't
have to reach to something you can't
afford either so what will this house
sell
for uh probably around two well best
best case scenarios 260 and you've owned
it how
long three and a half years okay all
right you have no capital gains on it
and you sell it and buy the next
property and uh what's your household
income uh this coming year it'll be 105
to 10 at least well you you can
definitely make a move and what's left
on the
mortgage um about 150 okay okay so
you're going have $100,000 Equity give
or take coming out of there and go buy
you something else yeah and I know Dave
she was worried about she said we got a
nice low interest rate so that she
doesn't want to let go of that which is
a problem a lot of people are facing out
there you either got the furnace and the
roof and all the crap falling down
around you or you got the interest rate
you got to I mean there's there's always
a tradeoff and so you got the hassle of
moving and not going to get to buy what
you want well of course you're not going
to buy what you want you you know things
always change so it's up to you but I
you know when you call me and all you
can talk about is all the money you've
spend on the thing you're done you're
done so stick a fork in it move on on
you know that's it and you can always
refinance later if rates go down you're
not stuck with that rate forever date
the rate marry the house get a good
house and don't worry about the rate
rate will come down when it comes down
refinance then you're fine you date the
rate marry the house and most people
fallowing the Ramy baby steps Dave if we
found pay off their home in seven years
you're not stuck even if you had that
interest rate you might have it for
seven years pay the dang thing off
upgrading cash on the next one and
you'll be okay lean into the process
here Karen is with us and Jacksonville
Florida hi Karen how are you hi Dave hey
what's up um I'm doing well it's it's an
honor to speak to you you too how can we
help uh well my husband and I have
actually gone through Financial Peace
University and were doing really well uh
we uh as of 2022 we were uh you know had
a fully funded business Safeguard
account we had our emergency fund funded
we had no debt other than our house and
uh at that time my husband got a not so
good medical diagnosis H so that set us
back that year and then ultimately he
decided to make a step into uh a
profession that he wanted to be in and
that essentially cut our income almost
in half for now um so he's doing he's
doing much better with that and and
moving forward progressing forward but
my question is um as a result of those
two things we we we had to you know tap
into those Safeguard accounts and pretty
much depleted most of them and now we've
got from credit card debt we have some
stock that is not in any kind of
retirement account so my question to you
is do I sell that stock and pay that
little bit of credit card debt that that
we do have now or should I let that
stock sit and just continue to not
accumulate anymore credit card debt but
you know just make payments on
that well what happens next
time what happens next time next time
there's a bump in the road and you land
on dad gum credit card again when are
you going to stop this
foolishness well um I mean we were able
to to do quite well for you know a while
and and until you
didn't you know until you started Living
on credit cards
again well we didn't really live on them
I mean yeah you did you bought crap you
couldn't afford to
buy well it was more monthly things that
we already had an obligation for um
because we weren't meeting our our
monthly budget so when you use the stock
to pay off the credit cards and the next
time you go on one of these Adventures
where you don't meet the monthly
obligations and you lean on credit cards
what are you going to do
then well I would hope he wouldn't be
back in this position I would hope you
would been here this
time I'm not going to give you
permission to say what you did was okay
what you did was not okay it was a
really bad dumb plan and if you're going
to use every time something comes along
to get yourself back into credit card
debt I can't help
you cuz youve used up your stock then so
if I tell you to cash out the stock and
then you go do this again you're screwed
girl you follow me
yeah I guess this was kind of a one-time
no it's not a one time thing though no
it's not always life's going to bring
you
something it's always going to be
something coming up until you decide no
matter what let me tell you when the
time is we're going to use a credit card
at the Ramsay never under any
circumstances we'll sell everything in
sight including the dog and three of the
grandkids we will never again go into a
credit card debt ever under any
circumstances period nothing will cause
that to happen we will be riding a
bicycle instead of driving a car but we
won't have debt ever see until you get
there kiddo you're going to go back
again you're going to go back again
you're going to go back again because
there's always something comes up
because there's a crack and as long as
there's a crack in the thing water is
going to leak through so yes you should
cash out the stock and you should pay
off the credit cards but you have got to
the two of you have got to sit down and
go we flunked Financial Peace University
we flunked the
class so we have got to reset and draw a
line This s and say never under any
freaking
circumstances are we ever going to have
a credit card in our
house cut it up close the accounts and
then you won't have the opportunity to
be blessed with the 22% APR from these
credit card companies that's the easiest
way to do do it cuz then you're going to
find another way when Deb's not an
option when Deb's off the table I got a
friend that lost his career he lost his
family he lost everything because of a
drinking problem he's now been dry for
30 years you know when he's going to
drink again never never you know when
the alcohol is going to be in his house
again never ever you got to decide this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
yeah
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsy Solutions on the
debt free stage Samantha's with us hi
Samantha how are you I'm wonderful how
are you guys doing better than we
deserve where do you live Dallas Texas
all right welcome to Nashville and how
much debt have you paid off
$57,200
66 way to go how long did that take 27
months good for you and your range of
income during that time 70,000 to 106
cool what do you do for a living I am a
dpmo so basically I'm a program manager
of operations wow good for you and what
kind of debt was the
$57,000 credit card debt I had medical
debt I had a car loan and the infamous
student loan debt you had it all you
were normal yes sir wow what a line up a
prize for collecting them all yeah
payche how old are you I'm 31 okay very
cool so what happened 27 months ago that
Samantha got a wakeup call and how'd you
get connected to us sure um so about a
year and a half before that I gave my
life to the Lord I was at my rock bottom
gave my life to the Lord and I got
serious about actually following God
about 6 months after that so started
reading the Bible and the Bible says
dead is bad so I had this plan that I
was going to pay off my student loan in
10 years and I told my brother-in-law
and my sister and they said well you can
actually pay it off in 2 years you can
actually pay off all of your debt they
said they did um they met this guy
Ramsey uh Dave Ramsey and they paid off
all of their debt oh wow yeah so um well
met you your show so um they did that
and I thought they were crazy I was like
they don't know how much dead I have so
um me being me I started doing some
research I got The Total Money Total
Money Makeover read the book I listened
to some of uh your teachings and what
really did it for me was listening to
the podcast because you had people of
all walks of life single people married
people younger people uh more tenur
people so um more tenur that was sweet
so nice that's what I am George I'm 10
years she didn't make eye contact with
you so that's good thought
yes so um yeah and then I started on the
plan um I want to be a good St of uh the
things that God has for me so amen where
did you go to church in Dallas uh Life
Fellowship in mckin yes very nice very
nice so you just leaned into the the
podcast after reading the book and
started following and doing the stuff
and just straight up did it I did um I
really got some momentum because my
credit card debt was smaller I was able
to do that within the first two months
but then um really getting after my car
and seeing how quickly I was able to pay
it off it really gave me momentum I
started um babysitting dog sitting house
sitting cat sitting lot of sitting yes
um I was in school getting my Ms when I
started this so um as you know with
getting an extended degree you don't
even have enough time to cry let alone
get a regular second job so I had to be
creative with it so I did that I learned
how to coupon and I cut down 98% of my
um personal expenses for like toiletries
and household items wow you like extreme
coupon or then I wouldn't say extreme
like you were getting paid at the store
the cashier like here's $20 yes they
they did I got good enough ated it where
they actually started um owing me money
when I would go couponing so and then I
started selling my stockpile I was able
to give some of it away to single moms
and people in need so yeah wow well
sounds like you you had a heart for
generosity throughout this whole process
which is beautiful yes which was hard
because you know I my money was going to
debt and I couldn't give it away out you
know outside of tithing but I got
creative that way to be able to still
give that's well done what's your
Master's in um I got my masters in
management with a um uh operations
Excellence yeah right there in your job
way to go so did you get a raise in this
process and promotion yeah that's a 70
to 106 right I did actually it's
actually an interesting story um I was
going to get laid off in the middle of
doing this so I started looking for
another job and I found the current job
that I so that my income went up to 85
and then they saw um they appreciated my
work ethic so they gave me a 20% raise w
wow very good very good good for you
thank you how fun your your sister and
brother-in-law got to be cheering they
are they would be here but my sister is
extremely pregnant so she couldn't
travel but I know they're watching and
I'm so thankful to them they cheered me
on every time I'd pay off $5,000 I'd be
like I still have 50 left but they were
excited like I paid everything off so
they were great cheerleaders and my
church family yes they um they would
take me out to eat because I wasn't
going out to eat I wasn't spending extra
money for Christmas they buy me clothes
because I would buy one pair of jeans a
year until literally I had holes in it
because I was trying to save as much
money as I can that's cool now yes yes
it is um well maybe not for work
but yes wow Samantha you're amazing
thank you you are amazing I'm so proud
of you hero thank thank you God is
amazing in me that's well done he is
amazing and uh so happy you found him
and that's what started the whole
process yes very very what do you tell
that person who's 29 and they're looking
at $57,000 in debt and they're like well
10 years maybe I'll pay off my student
loans what would you tell that person if
you were sitting across from them
getting coffee sure I would tell them to
look at how much interest they were
paying because that was what upset me I
would make a payment and so little was
going towards the principal and so much
was going towards the interest and it
was actually funny when I paid my car
off or I got close they called me and
asked me if everything was okay and I
said yeah I'm trying to pay my car off
but um I would say that the first thing
would be Jesus um it says in his word
that his faithfulness is a protective
shield when you're obedient to God's
word he's going to bless you my income
going up that was a blessing from God so
when you walk with him he will bless you
and then secondly endurance there's so
many quick
Quick Fix plans for getting out of debt
but um what I love about this plan it
taught me that I don't need to impulse
by that was a reality that I had to come
face to face with and also that I did
this to myself I swiped that credit card
I went and got that um car loan I did
those things but I was going to work
really hard to get out of debt and do
that and be an example to my nephew and
to my future children my sister and I
and my brother-in-law are first
generation believers so we want to show
the Next Generation that they can do
this without debt you can go to school
without debt you can get a master's I
was able to get my masters without
taking out additional money so um you
can do it I've had a surgery my dog got
sick all of that but because I was doing
this plan um and inflation because I was
doing this plan I was able to pay cash
for those things and I didn't have to
rely on a credit card or a loan to do
that Rockstar you're amazing wow ding
ding ding ding ding ding pretty
incredible you have changed uh your
family tree you've changed your whole
life uh the gospel has transformed you
yes very powerful very powerful well
done very very very well done I love it
so and when I guess I'm going to phrase
it again maybe George asked this but
let's see if we can do it one more time
boil it down if you told people to do
one thing or two things to get out of
debt what would you tell them to do
endurance endurance endurance don't quit
don't quit you can do it um 27 months is
a long time and 27 months is nothing yes
and you can be very creative I mean my
friends still had babies I was able to
coupon and get $110 worth of diapers for
41 um you can find different deals and
you know wow it's out there you're smart
enough to do it just cuz I have a
master's as a me I'm like overly smart
or anything you can figure out how to be
creative and how to get out there and
hustle it is possible to do it so you're
amazing well done hey we've got the live
and give Bo for you the baby steps
millionaires book cuz that's where
you're headed for sure Total Money
Makeover book to give to somebody and
give them some hope uh Financial Peace
University membership go through it or
give it away that's uh the live and give
box people buy it all the time but we're
going to give it to you to say thanks
for coming all the way from Dallas
congratulations Samantha Samantha from
Dallas Texas
$57,000 paid off in 27 months the coupon
queen from 70 to 106 counted down let's
hear a debt free Scream 3 2 1 all glory
be to God I'm debt
free
[Applause]
yeah I want to be Samantha when I grow
up man she's impressive be careful your
life will preach M wow powerful powerful
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
our scripture of the day Isaiah 41:10 so
do not fear for I am with you do not be
dismayed for I am your God I will
strengthen you and help you I will
uphold you with my righteous right hand
Tommy lorta said pressure is a word that
is misused in our vocabulary when you
start to think about pressure it's
because you've started to think of
failure H there we go Dakota is in
Dallas hi Dakota welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave thanks for taking my call
how are you better than we deserve
what's up in your
world hey so I am 27 years old I am
making a around
$76,000 a year between my full-time job
and a part-time job that I picked up
cool I am fortunate to not have any
credit card debt which is great and I'm
very thankful for that but I am sitting
around $45,000 in debt between my
student loans and a car loan um my
student loans are around 31,000 across
five loans with my highest interest rate
at 6.6% and then my car I have about
14,000 left at a 3.79% interest rate so
I'm sitting around six $6,600 in my
savings account and I followed along
with the show and hearing you know the
goal of having $11,000 in savings is
great however having that little amount
also gives me a lot of anxiety um just
thinking of you know random things that
could come up here and there car breaks
down you know extra expenses things like
that so I guess my question is with my
lowest student loan being around $3,000
technically I do have a savings account
to just start you know knocking that out
right away while still having a little
over 3,000 left in the account so I
guess the question is should I plan to
start drawing from that savings account
to start knocking those you know student
loans out in the car out paying extra
there um or should I leave that savings
account Alone look at refinancing I'm
not sure how deeply are you willing to
cut your lifestyle and how many hours
are you willing to work to where you
could do this in one
year yeah so 46 what did you say 40
41,000 right 45,000 about
45,000
76,000 out of 76,000 means you live on
m uh or you live on a little bit more
but you pay off everything in one
year yeah I'm really I I'm working about
40 to 50 hours for my full-time job
salari position um and then my part-time
job I was pulling an extra like 15 to 20
hours a week there there um at a retail
gig um for my mental health having that
much time working why does it hurt your
mental health to
work um just between the
responsibilities it's not that I don't
have the mental health or the capacity
to work I don't want to come across like
that you said for my mental health
that's a bunch of
crap yeah it was just to the point where
I was feeling super overwhelmed with the
amount of hours I was putting in I
wasn't yes because you did not have a
you the you did not you felt like a rat
in a wheel the you were not getting
traction if you were seeing this debt
drop off at $3 to $4,000 a month and you
knew you were going to be done a year
you'd be fine working but you were just
stuck working yeah I I did that's yeah
that's a good that's a better way of
putting it I felt really stuck I felt
like I was getting all this extra money
and then it I try working all the time
really hard if you got great traction is
not that
harsh right it's not what you want to do
the rest of your life but I want you to
be done in a year in that case
$1,000 as an emergency fund is not as
scary because you're going to be done in
a
year oh was wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute you have
almost $6,000 now right yeah I've got
about $6,600 in my savings account oh so
we're going to put 6,000 on the 45 now
we've only got 39 to do in a
year
wow so I guess to get further
clarification so the one that was on
like I said does give me a little bit of
anxiety because I just think I want you
to have a little bit of anxiety what's
giving you anxiety is
$45,000 in debt hanging over feeling
stuck when you are knocking off $3 to
$4,000 you're not going to have anxiety
you're going be knocking it out and then
you're going to be done you're going to
be 28 years old and not have a payment
in the world can you breathe that in I
know and what is your recommendation
because I think that is my
recommendation darling well I had to
replace two tires on my car so I think
if I would have only had ,000 Dollar in
my that's enough to replace two tires
and then you replenish it so you'd pause
the at snowball let's say that you have
another two tires go out pause the at
snowball your next paycheck's going to
cover the tire you already have a th000
in the emergency fund and then you move
on you just pick up where you left off
get the thousand bucks back instead of
3,000 or 4,000 going on your debt this
month only 2,000 does because you got to
buy some
tires okay that makes more sense okay
you got two new tires now so that that
problem's out of your way yeah there'll
be something else though there'll be
something else
break and you're going to be working all
the
time well you won't have time to spend
money right and don't worry just before
you die you'll pass
out yeah but hey I I'll pass out and be
de free
exactly I'm kidding with you kiddo but
listen if you the the trick is this we
have figured out that the more intense
people are the math almost quits working
you get out so fast because you create
this emotional spiritual momentum that
goes with a math momentum and it becomes
all-encompassing I mean you become like
like you joined a cult or something for
a short period of time right you don't
think about anything else for a short
period of time and then you're going to
be 28 years old and not have a payment
in the world and you've been playing
footsie with this stuff for almost a
decade mhm it's been hanging around like
a problem talk about anxiety
inducing yeah and I I am wanting to get
all of this taken care of you know my
boyfriend and I are both individually
trying to take care of our debt before
we decide to take that next step of
getting married and starting a family
and things like that so you don't have
to wait to get out of debt to be married
you just both have to both have to be in
agreement that we're going to get out of
debt that's all yeah that is true that
is true I'm I'm I'm ready to get it
knocked out though do it do it do it
Dakota Dakota Dakota I dare you to take
5600 and attack some debt today you're
going to get a little pep in your step
so hey
Samantha was just on here doing her debt
free scream she made $70,000 when she
started she paid off 57,000 27
months and finished her master's
degree and cash flowed all kinds of
expens that was right before you just a
minute ago single your age
just a minute ago go back and watch her
that free scream just a minute ago see
you you can absolutely do this you can
absolutely so get it Dakota Dakota
Dakota we're cheering you on hey we're
going to put you in Financial Peace
University and pay for it and we're
going to put you in the every dollar
premium so you can hook up and run your
budget and I want you to just go crazy
for a short period of time so you get
your life back and you you do that
Dakota you will never go back in debt
and you will become wealthy because you
will pay pay attention to money and make
it behave the rest of your life money is
a fabulous slave it is a horrible
master and it has been owning your butt
for a decade it's time you got on top of
it and you own it Dakota Dakota Dakota
she can do it George she do I just keep
thinking about this Mental Health crisis
in America and I think it has more to do
with debt than A1 thousand emergency
fund we're feeling out of control when
when when you're doing stupid stuff or
you're or don't have a sense of Destiny
everything is anxiety inducing I mean
stupid should induce anxiety they have a
direct you should you should have
anxiety if you're doing stupid stuff
shouldn't you that's your body telling
you this is not smart that's that's yeah
that's like you're not stupid really
should be anxiety inducing she's not
doing stupid but I'm just saying the but
I'm just in general you know and working
and not knowing where you're going like
she was talking about that that is that
does do that but hard work does not
cause mental health problems never has
as a matter of fact it solves a lot of
them actually talk to Dr John delone I
was talking about it with him on the air
the other day about this one of the
things that they tell people uh that
that are struggling with depression is
get
outside vitamin D and in engage in
physical
activity and get engaged in something
where you're seeing
traction all of those sound like work to
me so yeah work your butt off go crazy
for a short period of time and you know
work is not anxiety inducing ever well
it is if you're working for a toxic jerk
I take that back but yeah but I guess
but I mean just the essence of work
itself is not anxiety induc yeah so very
cool Dakota Dakota Dakota hold on
Austin's going to pick up we're going to
get you signed up for everything we're
going to give it to you cuz we believe
in you we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to Financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus
yeah